so
justin was my brother
i'm speaking for both my brother and i
and my family
so you hear a lot of people talking
about what a dedicated officer justin
was
about all the good service he did
he loved his job it was all he ever
wanted to do
for him it was a vocation
a calling
but aside from all that
justin was everything to his family
he was juicy or juice man
in light-hearted moments
but only to family and close friends
he was my brother
but so often he was my rock
no matter where i was in the world
i knew that justin was there for me
as he was for so many
when i was abroad and had to come back
to the states to deal with a difficult
situation in dc
justin flew across the country to meet
me there
and stayed just for moral support just
to be there with me
he's done that more than once
he was always there for me
and everyone in our family
whether it was to help with something
lend a sympathetic ear
provide a strong shoulder
or just for a hug
because justin's hugs were magic
he has
been especially important in my life
as a role model for my two sons
his nephew sebastian and asher
i always tell them that i'm raising them
to be good men
good men like their uncle justin and
uncle joshua
because they could have no better role
models
one of the last times i saw justin in
person
he took me aside just to tell me how
proud he was of me
and the job i was doing raising these
young gentlemen
even though he was my little brother
that meant so much to me
but i know that it's not just me
they are who they are
and my brothers and i are who we are
because of family
we have always recognized
how lucky we are
to have the family we have
justin and joshua had a connection
that few people on this earth will ever
experience
while very different
they're also the same in in many ways
the best ways
they often share the same thoughts
i can't tell you how many times they
showed up to something
wearing the same thing
and when they were little
they had their own language before they
learned to speak
justin had a presence about him
that not only commanded respect
but imparted respect
i dare anyone to find a single person
who could say anything bad about justin
even with someone he had a disagreement
with that person would still say that
justin was a good man
he could just de-escalate any situation
just with his natural demeanor
to every officer who knew justin i will
say this
justin's watched
in the physical world over his sons sean
and jacob has ended
now it's up to you to help fill that
role
keep watch over these boys
and be there in the way that their
father cannot
and the same for stacy
justin was so lucky to have found his
other half
and even though their time together
was shorter than it should have been
they both brought each other so much joy
i'm so happy
that my brother got to experience that
kind of love in his life
which was cut way too short
so while physically departed
justin will remain with us in so many
ways
quiet nights under the stars
walking on a trail
hearing a familiar song
visiting a special place
justin will be with us
and even in this unbearable grief
i can close my eyes
and feel justin's hug
and hear his voice
say that it's gonna be okay
at first i wasn't not sure if i could
even stand up here or even make it up
here
but i think with this podium and
my family and and god
i'll be able to say a few words
justin was my son a best friend
another best friend
family of best friends
he was humble
he was my hero
i told him once after we had sat and
talked for a few minutes we shared our
thoughts for the day
and i told him
you're my hero
and justin in his way said
dad just doing my job just doing my job
well
when justin did his job he did it like
he lived his life
honesty
and integrity
and integrity
and again
what everybody says
if you ever got a justin hug
you know y'all done being hugged
david no no little little yeah no man
you got a
hug was talking with his nephews
sebastian and asher
and i don't know who was consoling who
at that time
and i said you know guys you know we
just got to think about
the good times the happy times that we
had with your uncle justin
and they both looked up and they said
but grandpa there were no other times
there were no bad times no unhappy times
all we had was good times with uncle
justin
and so we all i know his squad members
fellow officers
you've had good times
with justin
cherish those times
and never forget him
and thank you all
you